how does digital bollocks compared to
the black magic or red epic a lot of
people have pitted us against the black
magic camera in their reviews and then
online and things like that but we don't
see it that way to us the if you look at
the percentage of people right now that
are shooting raw emotion picture it's
very well compared to the amount of
people shooting h.264 and to us the goal
is grow the raw market to as big as we
can possibly grow it because everybody
black magic and red and alexa act on
everybody will share a part of that
market and and our goal right now is to
get that to be as big as possible
because that will benefit everybody in
the market and it it's I hope it's
really the feature of the way motion
picture is going and will continue to go
and and we just want to be part of that
you